we're told that triangle p i n is
rotated negative 270 degrees about the
origin so this is the triangle p i n and
we're going to rotate it negative 270
degrees about the origin
draw the image of this rotation using
the interactive graph the direction of
rotation by a positive angle is
counterclockwise so positive is
counterclockwise which is a standard
convention and well this is negative so
negative degree would be clockwise and
we want to use this tool here and this
tool i can i can put points in or i
could delete points i can draw a point
by clicking on it so what we want to do
is think about well look if we rotate
the points of this triangle around the
origin by negative 270 degrees where is
it going to put these points and to help
us think about that i'm i've i've copied
and pasted this on our scratch pad so
actually let me let me go over here so i
can actually draw on it
so let's just first think about what a
negative 270 degree rotation actually is
so
if i were to start
if i were to let me draw some coordinate
axes here
so that's the x-axis and that's a y-axis
if you were to start
right over here
and you were to rotate around the origin
by negative so this is the origin here
by negative 270 degrees what would that
be
well let's see this would be rotating
negative 90. this would be rotating
negative another negative 90 which would
together would be negative 180 and then
this would be another negative 90 which
would give you in total
negative 270 degrees that's negative 270
degrees now notice that would get that
point here which we could have also
gotten there by just rotating it by
positive 90 degrees
we could have just said that this is
equivalent to a positive 90 degree
rotation
so if they want us to rotate the points
here around the origin by
negative 270 degrees that's equivalent
to just rotating all of the points and
i'll just focus on the vertices because
those are the easiest ones to to think
about to visualize
i can just rotate each of those around
the origin by positive 90 degrees
but how do we do that and to do that
what i'm going to do
to do that what i'm going to do is i'm
going to draw a series of right
triangles
so let's first focus on
actually let's first focus on
point i right over here and if i were to
let me draw a right triangle and i could
draw it several ways
but let me draw it
like this
so it's a right triangle
where the line between the origin and i
is its hypotenuse so let me see if i can
it's i could probably draw
i could use a line tool for that
so let me
so that's the hypotenuse of the line
now if i'm going to rotate i 90 degrees
about about the origin that's equivalent
to rotating this right triangle 90
degrees so what's going to happen there
well this side
right over here if i rotate
if i rotate this 90 degrees
where is that going to go well instead
of going 7 along the x-axis it's going
to go 7 along the y-axis so it's going
to it's going to if you rotate it
positive 90 degrees
that side is going to look like this
so that's rotating it
90 degrees just like that now what about
this side over here
what about
this side let me do this in a different
color
what about
this side right over here
well this side over here notice we've
gone down from the origin we've gone
down seven but if you were to rotate it
up notice these this forms a right angle
between this magenta side and this blue
side so you're going to form a right
angle again and so from this point
you're going to go straight as a right
angle and instead of going down 7 you're
going to go to the right 7. so you're
going to go to the right 7
just like this
and so your the point i or the
corresponding point in the image after
the rotation is going to be right over
here so that green line
let me draw the hypotenuse now
it's going to look it's going to look
like
whoops i wanted to do that in a
different color i wanted it in the green
i have trouble changing colors
all right so there you go it's going to
look
it's going to look like that so your new
point i if you if you rotate this
triangle this right triangle 90 degrees
your new point uh maybe i shouldn't say
i'll call it i prime
which is
what is the image of this point after
i've done the 90 degree rotation is
going to be right over here and now we
can do that for each of the points we
can do that for n here let's draw a
right triangle let's draw a right
triangle and i could do it a bunch of
different ways i could draw it i could
draw a right triangle like this let me
draw it like this so that's one side of
my right triangle so let me draw the
hypotenuse first so i have the
hypotenuse
connects the origin
to my point just like that and then i
could i could either draw it up here or
i could draw it down here
like
this
i could draw it like this so if you
rotate this 90 degrees if you rotate
this 90 degrees
this side
which is 7 units long and we're going
seven below the origin it's now going to
be seven to the right right if i rotate
it by 90 degrees it's going to be right
over here
it's going to be here and this side
which has length this let me switch
colors
this side which has length two it forms
a right angle so we're going to form a
right angle and have length two right
over here
and so your the image of point n is
going to be let me
get the right color it is going to be
just like that it is going to be
the image of point n is going to be
right here i'll call that n prime so we
know where the new where the image of i
is the image of n is so now we just have
to think about where does the image of p
sit and once again we can do our little
right triangle idea
so let's draw a right triangle
so
just like that i could draw that side
and i can do this side right over here
so if i were to rotate if i were to
focus on this let me do some color i
haven't so if i were to focus on i've
already used that color
if i were to focus on this right over
here and if i were to rotate it by 90
degrees instead of going 2 to the right
it's going to go too straight up if i
rotate this by 90 degrees it's going to
be just like this
now
this side on let me let me pick another
color
this side right over here forms a right
angle
and it has a length of three so we're
going to form a right angle here and
have a length of three
and just like that we know where the
image of p is going to be
it is going to be
it is going to be right over here
so this is p prime and i know it's kind
of confusing but now we have to con we
now have to connect the p prime the i
prime and the n prime to figure out what
the image of my triangle is after
rotation so let me do that
so if i connect these two i get that if
i connect
these two
i get that and if i connect these two
if i connect those two i have that and
there you have it i have the image and
now i just have to input it on the
actual problem
so let's see point negative three comma
two let me get it out
so negative three comma two is there
i have seven
comma two so let me
put that in there
seven
comma two
and then i have seven comma seven is
there
so let me get this out so seven
comma seven and then to i'll draw here
again to connect the lines and i'm done
i've rotated it through an angle of 90
degrees
or negative 270 degrees which is what
they originally they originally asked me
for and i can check to make sure i got
the right answer